european union finance ministers have
given a green light to the european
commission to negotiate toughest savings
tax agreements with non-eu countries
Switzerland Liechtenstein Monaco and
Dora and San Marino the decision is part
of EU moves to clamp down on tax evasion
and tax fraud at their meeting in
Brussels The ministers also pledged to
promote good tax practices and tax
governance in countries outside the EU
high on the agenda were plans to
strengthen rules for taxes on savings
income the plan is to make it possible
to tax all kinds of savings income and
products that generate interest as well
as make it harder to get around the
rules currently in place we also had
good discussions today on the savings
tax directive not all Member States were
able to agree to these proposals a day
we expect that this issue will be on the
agenda of the European Council next week
The ministers also agreed to amend the
EU budget for this year with an
additional 7.3 billion euros moves
toward an EU banking Union were on the
table to the ministers discussed new
rules aimed at pre-empting bank crises
and dealing with problems like
insolvency when they happen the measures
would establish the order in which
investors would be obliged to help bail
out an institution in trouble there was
broad agreement that depositors was less
than 100,000 euros in savings would not
be called on to contribute more broadly
the rules would require banks and
investment firms to draw up recovery
plans laying out the measures they would
take to restore their financial health
if things turn sour